trouble at the tills
the price of staple foods has soared in
recent months with as many as two in
every five britons now buying less to
eat
and for the first time in 40 years
inflation the gradual increase in the
cost of goods and services across a year
rose to nine percent with the governor
of the bank of england warning of
apocalyptic food price hikes
further back the supply chain the
middlemen are trying their best to
absorb the rising costs this is london's
biggest wholesale food market where the
industry is experiencing a perfect storm
of problems from the pandemic to brexit
and more recently the war in ukraine the
crisis going on in ukraine uh with the
floods going on in spain the various uh
packaging costs fuel costs
brexit hasn't helped as well in terms of
all the uh the extra paperwork has to be
done who knows what's around the corner
if the war continues it's going to get
worse the winter's going to make it
worse
look what we're looking at now the the
cost of heating the cost of electricity
it's all going up and up and up
russia and ukraine are some of the
world's largest producers of cooking
oils fertilizers and grains used in
everything from bread to animal feed but
the conflict means goods are stuck in
ports or rotting in fields
producers and sellers are used to
dealing with unpredictable situations
from low yields to economic pressures to
supply chain problems but rarely have
the issues come this thick and fast
leaving no time for companies to recover
leaving everybody from field to fork
counting the cost
and what's a worry for wealthy western
consumers is potentially catastrophic
for some of the world's poorest
in somalia already crippled by drought
the war in ukraine's push fuel and
fertilizer prices up by 40 percent while
in india a decision to ban grain exports
to protect domestic supplies threatens
to push global wheat prices even higher
in the uk the national dish fish and
chips is the canary in the coal mine
oil's going up petrol has gone up
diesel's gone up
it all adds on to everything and joe
publix paying for it we're all paying
for it and how much more can we pay for
the cost of cooking oils increased 30
percent in three months and cod and
haddock are becoming more expensive as
global warming's driving fish stocks
further north forcing fishermen to spend
longer at sea and now russian fish has
disappeared from the market
industry bosses fear a third of the uk's
fish and chip shops could close in the
next nine months
as the world bounces back from the
pandemic it's now out of the frying pan
and into the fire
nevaka al jazeera london